let's go and own reject nation its Greg
Alba here and it's John Humphrey over
here so John are continuing shooting
after sweating from the gym but we got
no time to shower Polaroid remember
those things there's a trailer out based
off of Polaroids yeah it's a horror
movie whole story about make it date is
your buddy who pull the road the look
scaredy Cameron something appears and I
believe tagline for this movie is once
you take it it takes you so an evil
camera I don't want to be negative about
this let's just watch it with an open
mind so Cameron boy
hey ready to party yaaaa
I get that camera
where'd you get it I worked at this
antique store people are not really
trying to hold her but she's now seeing
anything else different you'll see
starter droopy antique shop yeah I was
dead what I think you're all in danger
what are you talking about Tina shadow
after Tyler died the shadow moves to
this photo I think if the shadow moves
peacefully with you dying it's a really
freak show give her the game today I'm
soft it has a lighter
[Music]
all right my name's to deal with tragedy
just to make up urban legends except
this wasn't an urban legend this is real
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all their interstitial stuff is cool
they're like noises and time John I
think there's plenty to not like about
this trend some things to really like
about this room yeah I mean I know that
this is from the people who did the ring
and the grudge reboot the producers of
that yeah told then I get you know uh
vaguely it's almost like a jailer said
maybe I'm just thinking about shudder at
jr. movie about the evil camera I think
you're kind of spot on there some of
this looks like it would be a real
bunker I think a lot looks dumb and some
was pretty cool yeah I like the effect
would you know kind like that voodoo
effect of the polaroid catching off
arthur ham was yeah that was cool i like
when they put it out in a pitch regrown
back that was that was the coolest part
of the whole trailer yeah everything
else honestly looks really cliche yeah
we didn't have any pictures and shadow
travels we were joking about like what
it could be like when we heard it's
called Polaroid hormone like the up this
modern old camera and exactly what I was
expecting it today yeah and I had
teenagers in high school and oh you're
ridiculous no one believes in scary
stuff halfway through something spooky
happens now they're starting to believe
it seems like a tiring cliche it was
like I wanted more of that kind of stuff
all this stuff would like demons and
grabbing her head that was kind of silly
but I but then there's like little
moments like what the go she come like
the go sheet beam ghost that was a cool
little effect that they had at one point
oh yeah yeah they're like comes down and
it conforms to a shape and it detects
that guy like that I mean like
supernatural elements like that were
cool yeah yeah that's
go ahead put it because even even with
the hands even when that stuff is cheesy
that's still the kind of stuff that
makes me go well I want to see it really
I want to see it was not this movie
specifically but like in these trailers
those are the things they're usually
redeeming where I'm like oh wonder what
your monster is and I wonder how it's
going to connect yeah I'll have a door
nothing it is a camera and then it does
this weird thing I don't know enough
about a glove in the movie but I'm like
1/2 my Polaroids are the oldest [ __ ]
things in the planet yeah well I don't
know I mean like that could have been a
throwaway like oh it's that like you
know people have said about stuff that
they know because they mean like Oh
where'd you get it I haven't seen her in
a while like I don't know if he's is
unfamiliar with the concept overall but
less than 10 years ago we'd still be in
high school we saw her in high school
there are still are Polaroids
do they make new ones nowadays they
still make ones you can go to Best Buy
and buy one that will make you more oil
maybe that's a nitpicky little thing I
have about the film no I know nothing
looks she sees gimmicky too gimmicky to
me the high school kids look incredibly
cliche how they do they look and it's
also like I don't know and this is a
nitpick but you know when you have those
characters worth like oh you work in a
weird place you work in an antique shop
and it's like I don't really you don't
look like you work in an antique shop
which anybody can work anywhere but yeah
there's something weird about like
everything looks a little too polished
it's another one of those words like
I've seen these characters and I've seen
this kind of story and everything looks
really pretty there are elements that
seem alright it's the execution overall
even like scary stuff that are supposed
to be scary the way the shots are all
done detention stuff they're trying to
build it looks so generic and it's kind
of nice a little setting to me the whole
thing of the sheriff in town
you know kids justified these things to
deal with like the makeup urban legends
and then know this is a real person they
have like the old newspapers that talk
about these things in yeah it doesn't
seem to be checking off every every
other or trouble bullet kaileena
yeah and you know once once once we're
done watching this trailer I just feel
like another one of the endless stream
afraid yeah yeah there's not a lot
special to me about this and it I almost
feel like this movie got a got a boost
somewhere like this maybe wasn't gonna
be as you know getting the roll out you
know and now it got bumped up like 47
meters down I think was a similar kind
of movie where that was just supposed to
go to VOD or you know TV or something
but then the shallows do really well so
it got too booked I mean I'm happy to
see dimension films we're talking about
Italy being like a big done it yeah let
my time running do the scream and Spike
it to men to never ever to do it so it's
cool to see them doing a horror movie
again unless this trailer is hiding
something that's not
yeah that's right because the other
thing too I got the the sense for was
like maybe there's not actually a whole
lot of you know you see the hands and
you see the ghost shape but maybe
there's actually not a whole lot of like
supernatural stuff that shows up on
screen a lot throughout this movies and
maybe it's going to be one of those
where there are a couple money shots at
best and the rest is kind of run of them
yeah I kind of seems semi ripoff of
final destination as well boy you know
you take the picture and then like
wherever the shadow goes oh like death
is falling in yeah the death is falling
is specifically choosing who's gonna be
next like giving you a heads up of who's
gonna die next okay based off the mass
of whatever death is presenting okay not
too much I don't know I looks lit looks
like crap to me I'm trying to find
positive things to say but I know
positive this is better than anything
we've ever shot maybe I mean we we
wouldn't know how I mean we've never
shot anything on this caliber a short
film wise we've never made a feature
film
so hey kudos to you guys for at least
putting something together and another
positive we don't know for sure it's
just a trailer granted 98.5% of the time
we're correct somebody in the comment
says this looks like final destination
plus safe she's and die
you know goosebumps let's weed you yeah
a little bit of the first we just
somebody else had Riverdale see them too
I can see all of these then yeah you
know it's like completely original
concept yeah yeah Polaroid I hold this
type you know would have been cooler the
Civil War Pony things yeah you karetai
yeah yeah silver placemat an antique
camera right there no seriously what is
that yeah I get kids like what is it
like so many kids are saying it's in the
trailer what is this I'm like it's a
freaking polar have you not recognized
yeah for a second there it's kind of
cool to thing like oh there's a spooky
movie just called Polaroid and it's so
ubiquitous but I feel like if you're
gonna do that you gotta you get really
distinctive by yourself yeah cuz yeah
and somebody pointed out the first Ouija
- and yeah yeah I get that vibe well
guys are you excited to see Polaroid and
Dia hate us for not liking the trailer
how do you feel how do you think we're
being too harsh for not having seen the
movie yet
or do you think we're probably right
subscribe anyway click that like button
I hear that does things for YouTube
channels share this video I also hear
that does things click that notification
bells so many requirements on your end
all are your free viewing experience is
John dad John Humphrey debt on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
Dimension Films hahaha bum house danke
Dom go check out that's why we're
bagging on this because they're
competing horror I want them all to do
well good horror is good whole I don't
believe in that method that if they do
well we do well when cam if I use like
if DT does well that just makes that is
helps us do well overall don't believe
that don't believe I believe they gotta
go down the [ __ ] to met comedy send
better
yeah monopolies are where at that you
know only one person doing everything
okay pulley right guys if you invite us
to a free screening yeah will totally
give it a lot of chase will give it a
lot of phrase it's how it's all
youtubers do it right we won't we won't
stick to our guns
totally kiss your ass patreon patreon
it's pointless
you get no benefits if you go over there
reverse psychology
yeah facts don't check it out don't
check you don't want to see what so II
don't
it's I don't think you could handle
what's over yeah yeah hold on Satan's
nothing you see my new trailer give
those guys my camera they want to borrow
what they do is my Satan voice let's
Satan sounds like to me Satan's actually
a conscientious guy